well let's let's jump back to the the
nightmare scenario that is what the
government is doing and uh outside of
the the insanity of the left so so the
general idea I guess like the reason I
wanted to get into that is that you've
got this cultural movement which is just
chaos it's fire it's rot it's
destructive and you can see that at the
federal level I feel like they really
really are panicking this idea of
balkanization is real when the states
starts saying Fu when they were like yo
we're gonna lock down in Texas and
Florida like nah Joe Biden said we we're
gonna have to lock down more meanwhile
people are partnering it up in some of
these states clearly having no Authority
check out the story from the New York
Post the White House is flagging posts
for Facebook to censor over coveted
misinformation we also saw that story
where the bind Administration and the
DNC were talking with text message
providers phone companies to censor text
messages oh we crossed that Rubicon baby
this is it that's no no no we haven't
crossed the roof bro what happened I
mean when when Jen sackey can go on TV
and say she emphasized the word four she
goes we are flagging for Facebook I was
like whoa that's not constitutional in
any stretch of the imagination when they
would normally do something like this
they would go we are not telling
Facebook what to do we are merely asking
them to enforce their rules to help this
country even that is questionable the
government can't go to a private company
and say censor this they can't she's
saying they're doing it they talk about
going after our text messages bro that
rubicon's been crossed so who's Caesar
in this metaphor Joe Biden no no one
would follow him in the battle come on
man hairy legs no fighting Gumball
Caesar Amber that's not I don't know
what to do now I think the wonderful
thing is there's no Cult of Personality
here if there was a cult leader
Democratic president that people were
obsessed with we might we might see this
a trump yeah but he wasn't the
Democratic leader like if there was a
Democrat if Biden was not Biden but some
yeah crazy cult leader we would have
that would be Rubicon danger where he
could turn it into an Empire we have a
we have a very strong First Amendment so
when you do stuff like this that's not
technically a formal attack on the First
Amendment that's referred to as chilling
free speech and you're not allowed via
Supreme Court decisions to chill free
speech in that way I don't no I think
this is overt like they're not saying
they're not saying we're going to censor
it they're trying to do an end around to
censor indirectly so like that's the
maneuver that they would be using but
that's also unconstitutional it's called
Free Speech no I think chilling free
speech is different I'm pretty sure
um if the the gov uh the Democrats are
being sued over this in California if
the government goes to a private company
and says censor this it is the
government taking an overt action not
chilling they're literally the ones
doing the sense the way that you phrased
it it was like we're not saying censor
it but we're flagging this for Facebook
no no know I'm saying normally what the
Democrats or the government would do is
say the government is not in the
business of censoring Americans right
we're just letting Facebook know when
there's misinformation and they can deal
with it as they see fit that's not what
they're doing right that's what you'd
expect them to do what they're doing now
is saki is literally saying we are
flagging it for them to remove okay so
that's that's what I that's right that's
that's overtly it would be like this
imagine if the federal government was
like
we hired
um uh Securitas to go uh uh detain a
bunch arrest a bunch of people who are
at church because they're Christian
you're not going to be like uh that that
that's okay because a private company
did it well the government hires them to
do it the government instructs them to
do it you they can't that's literally
what they're doing right now this is
this is like the under or maybe it will
lead to the official return of operation
choke point which was under the Obama
Administration where they would Target
certain sketchy borderline Industries
and reach out to the banking companies
and payment processes and all that and
get them to stop doing business with
them and the whole point was like we're
going to do human trafficking but then
all of a sudden people who are like
legitimately actors in the porn industry
would lose their bank accounts right
they're like we're gonna do gun
smuggling but all of a sudden federally
licensed firearm dealerships would lose
their bank accounts so like the Obama
Administration in well not formally
created a list of Industries and like
industries that they determined to be
adjacent to problems in the country and
they use federal power to get rid of
that then Trump comes into office and
these companies almost continue that
program in his absence and now Biden's
back and he's like well let's formalize
what you guys have been doing already
here's the next Glenn Greenwald tweets
the White House is admitting that
they're compiling lists of people who
they claim are posting content they
regard as problematic and that
constitute misinformation and our
demanding Facebook remove them this is
authoritarianism
so how long until the White House puts
out their list of extremists content
producers and they say the
insurrectionists were following these
people which of course is going to
include most of the people you you know
and love because people follow a lot of
people I you know you know what they
won't do they won't point out that many
of these same people will be following
Brian stelter on CNN well but that's not
relevant but you'll see Crowder's name
in there you know stick sex and Hammer
was like I hope I make the list what
happens when they do that and then they
say the the extremists those who espouse
incitement to Insurrection that is
illegal and we're going to shut down
their accounts right yeah I mean look I
was told by one of these quote-unquote
insurrectionists that never went into
the building that they watch my content
so like oh I inspired an extremist I I
somehow may have inspired somebody
that's further to the right than me much
further according to to this like
interpretation but yeah it's definitely
a huge problem that they're that they're
doing this and that they keep pushing
the gas on censorship again it's it's an
informal or it's I'm sorry it's the
formalization of what was already
happening while Trump was in office what
became normal and like the Bible
Administration is totally cool with it
and we're not we shouldn't be surprised
because remember when Obama played the
Facebook algorithm the Facebook guys
came up to him after he won his election
and they were like we knew what you were
doing and we thought it was so cool
because we were on your side yeah Trump
plays the Facebook algorithm they
changed the rules completely Reddit yeah
read it the the Donald dominated the
front page about it all the time so they
were like we're going to remove the
Donald from the front page period as
soon as Republicans figured out how to
use the internet they were like well you
know we got to have authoritative
services so what if 95 of the mainstream
media except for foxes is left-leaning
don't worry about it it's going to be
authoritative and now they're untethered
the left is completely untethered from
society because of once big Tech started
playing that game of weak and will ban
the conservatives and that's literally
what they're doing there are some people
on the left who get banned don't get me
wrong there's a lot of them
but when people saw and I don't think it
was it was an intentional movement I
think it was a natural progression that
you've you've got left and right and
Facebook and Twitter and YouTube say
this chunk of the right is gone and this
chunk of the left is gone now the whole
Overton window went and shifted farther
left you get the rainbow bleep bleep
monkey I can actually I think you can
say butt that's rainbow bleep butt
monkey that's very interesting because
physically if you had a structure of two
two pieces and you removed one of them
like the far the far right you said was
removed that would release the scent
like you said it actually said
untethered like it's you've removed the
counterweight exactly exactly another
way to put it is if you're if if your
left fingertips get get removed in an
accident but your whole right hand is
removed an accident and you're
right-handed now you're going to be
left-handed you can still use your right
arm for things providing support but all
of a sudden now everything's gonna shift
to the left where the resources are so
so long as the censorship is 80 percent
conservative and twenty percent left
everything's going to shift to the left
because it's untethered there's nothing
holding them back anymore so what do you
get drag queen Story Hour
because they don't care about what what
Republicans say because you will get
banned for criticizing these communities
if you say what your issue with it is
your band then it levels up now you've
got rainbow bleep butt monkey showing up
at the library and the parents going
what and screaming and freaking out
anatomically correct someone put on yeah
we can't I won't talk too much about it
but they walk that back in the UK for
you know the next couple months they're
never going to do anything like that
again but the drag queen Story Hour I've
been on this for years because I do a
partnership with the David Horowitz
Freedom Center right and that's not just
in public libraries in certain districts
in this country that's in our Public
Schools so if you pay taxes you're
paying for drag queen Story Hour for
these people to come to your school read
to your kids and all the books are about
how like you know you should probably
think about gender transitioning like
kindergartner have you ever considered
this do you uh
you ever been to a strip club yes Ian
yeah Lydia no I have not but but I was
there because I knew somebody that owned
it so what a lot of people don't know is
that in many states maybe even most they
don't get fully nude in fact in many of
these lame yeah it's true though it's
topless only with if you have alcohol
you can't have full nude a lot of times
with alcohol in a lot of States
but how are they still in business with
the internet just questions people like
to be there physically yeah but the
other thing too is some place aren't
even topless some some states don't even
allow topless so you ask someone what is
it stripping and they're going to assume
full nude that's actually not true
that's actually not true there are
places sure just when they take off the
beanie yes then here's the point if you
went to say I don't know Jank euger of
The Young Turks and asked them if they
would support children taking off their
clothes on stage as adult men would you
support an 11 year old boy on stage
taking office clothing while adult men
gave money to him every time he did
no of course the boy was still wearing
shorts and a t-shirt underneath his
outfit but it was pulling off the
clothes and then getting money do you
think they would support that I actually
think right now they wouldn't give you a
straight answer because they'd be like
what are you talking about what are you
trying to say I don't trust what you're
asking it's a straightforward question
the point is Chen cougar actually
defended child stripping I'm not
exaggerating this is not a hyperbole
there is I'm not going to say the name
of the child who does what they call
drag shows but drag shows are
conspicuously similar to stripping where
he he goes on the stage as a bunch of
adults throw money to him and give give
him money as he takes his clothing off
and so I saw that and I immediately was
like now that looks like stripping
called some people I knew who who worked
in the industry asked them some
questions and they said I I didn't ask
them about the drag show I said what
would you call this and I said a person
on stage taking off an outer layer of
clothing to reveal undergarments maybe a
t-shirt and shorts while adults in the
audience are giving money as they do it
and they're like that's stripping and I
said in in that that as I described it
like of course and I was like but they
don't get naked but you don't always get
naked and I'm like okay so that would be
stripping yes absolutely these are
people I know who have who have worked
in some women in multiple States and
they explain and they're like in Vegas
here's how it works Vegas is like they
got brothels in in like the Dakotas it's
actually like this in in red states that
are more religious oh man you can't even
you have to be wearing like a full top
so quite literally it's
indistinguishable and Jank Huger has a
show where he actively defends the
practice
so when we're at that level
I don't know I don't know what to say
man that is untethered that is what
untethered means
I saw that high profile Progressive
YouTube channel
with millions of followers and he
actively says pre-bubescent boys taking
off their clothing for adult men at a
bar for money is okay I'm like what no
I'm sorry dude you've crossed the line
you're untethered from reality because I
can sit here and be like I actually
think we need basic Universal Health
Care with private supplemental insurance
I'm in favor of that I'm actually in
favor of universal parental leave I
think we've got a big problem with
parents not being there for their kids I
think if we had if we had that some way
solidify would be fantastic I think we
got a huge problem that businesses are
tied to healthcare I think Andrew Yang
was right about that and uh I think The
Young Turks have lost their minds when
they defend child child stripping yeah
well I mean you better stop attacking
Jank otherwise Anna's gonna blackmail
you but
um but uh yeah no uh Jank saying that is
ridiculous and they are very like
weasily about it because they'll deny it
but then they'll say how they're in
favor of it like that's the trick that's
not happening but also you're weird and
creepy for being against it even though
even even under drag circumstances so I
I asked around typically they leave the
money for whichever drag person is on
the stage in like a jar away from that
so you're not throwing them yeah you
don't have the image of them flinging
dollar bills up there and that's not
even just a kid on a stage getting that
image it's also like after midnight yeah
like what are you doing without those
I'm pretty sure they were drinking right
I don't want to I don't want to say
things unless I'm absolutely sure so
either way it's it's untethered so what
happens is
when you have a tribalism The Blob it's
absorbing institutions and now the blob
is saying that these things should
happen which are horrifying it's
disgusting
Jank is scared that if he says the wrong
thing he'll offend his audience so he
defends it and they had Jordan klepper
from Comedy Central saying isn't it so
great to hear what this this kid has to
say about being an advocate and I'm like
you people are nuts you've gone so far
off the rails it used to be you know
when I grew up that the conservatives
would argue something and it was an
argument ah no you can't do that safe
legal and rare for abortion now it's
Lena Dunham saying she wish she got an
abortion or whatever whatever she said
yeah things like that they've untethered
thanks for checking out this clip from
the Tim cast IRL podcast if you want to
see the full show come back to this
channel youtube.com
timcastirl Monday through Friday at 8pm
where you can leave comments and Super
Chat and we actually will read your
comments on the show don't forget to
like share subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else go to
timcast.com become a member and we even
have full bonus episodes thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time